[Music]
[Music]
what's up guys mkbhd here I bet I'm not
the only one to speak to the CEO of
Microsoft while wearing an Apple watch
and I bet I'm not the only one to chat
with Bill Gates with an Apple watch on
and I bet he's also probably noticed
though it's not that I'm trolling nobody
doing that is trolling it's just that
it's the default at this point the Apple
watch is everywhere it's the default
SmartWatch for the iPhone which is also
everywhere so after a couple of my
tweets some of you guys wanted to know
my full thoughts on Apple watch Series 5
the latest and greatest version of it
that just came out for this holiday
season
spoiler alert i've already tweeted most
of my thoughts but i'll put them all in
one video here in one place so I have
the 44 millimeter instead of the 44 that
bigger face bigger battery even though I
don't have a huge wrist I think it looks
just fine and I went with Space Gray
aluminum so I keep that dark matte
finish and I've had no durability issues
on my other aluminum Apple watches and
yes just to get it out the way I do wear
it on my right wrist
even though I'm a righty I guess I'm
just backwards like that so if you
remember that Apple event just a couple
weeks ago there weren't really all that
many new features with the new Apple
watch you know there's a new brushed
titanium finish that looks really cool
and there's also the other ceramics and
stainless steel and things like that and
there's some other new features and some
new bands but really the main new
feature of Apple watch Series 5 is the
always-on display so technically
speaking this new Apple watch is able to
maintain the always-on display with a
new display technology that keeps it lit
up dimly but lit up all the time at a
variable refresh rate so it's called
LTP o which stands for low temperature
poly-silicon and oxide which doesn't
really matter as much as just knowing
that this involves a special controller
and certain hardware that's only in
Apple watch Series 5 so there can't be a
software update to make the series 3 or
series 4 do always-on it's just in
series 5 so the display itself it'll
look just as good and it'll get just as
bright and it's just a familiar OLED
you're used to looking at but now it's
always on so tip
when you're using an Apple watch the
OLED refreshes at 60 frames per second
for 60 Hertz that's why animations are
smooth everything looks normal and a
second hand if you have one on your
clock face sort of smoothly rolls around
in a circle this is still the case here
with this new version but when you stop
using it or you put it down it goes into
always-on mode the display dims and it
ratchets down to refresh as low as one
Hertz or one time every second which is
fine because it hides the second hand
and it doesn't have to show you
constantly refreshing information and
things smoothly on the screen so it can
still show you the time all the time and
save a ton of power by not still
refreshing at 60 Hertz so okay what are
the benefits of this always-on display
you may ask if you've never used any
other SmartWatch well if you've had an
Apple watch before then you're already
used to this gesture you have to do to
get it to recognize that you're looking
at it and to light up whatever your
latest notification is or just see the
time sometimes you can get pretty good
at it doing it subtly but it's a pretty
obvious gesture but of course sometimes
it's just kind of hard or just
straight-up inconvenient to do that
whole gesture and you just want to be
able to glance over at it and see the
time or just check something real quick
without the whole obvious wrist movement
maybe you're driving or riding a bike
and don't want to switch to one hand or
maybe you're typing and you just want to
look down and glance at the time without
stopping or maybe you're in just a
social situation or it'd be kind of rude
to check the time with the huge sweeping
gesture so these are all real situations
and that is why people wanted always on
just the glance ability but the most
controversial trade off here with
always-on is battery life so Apple
claims that the variable refresh rate is
what will help you not obliterate your
battery life it's going down to this way
low-power mode and it's true it doesn't
completely crush your battery but I have
definitely noticed that having the OS on
display always-on does hurt your battery
life I personally went from ending the
day with 50 something percent left to
ending a normal day with 20 to 30% left
and that's not the end of the world
that's definitely still clearly all-day
battery life for my usage which is high
brightness
getting plenty of notifications frequent
workouts things like that but I did
still notice that hid and on a day with
a longer outdoor workout where it's
using GPS and it's just always on you
can actually get close to killing the
Apple watch in a day which I never did
before always on and I did some more
on-and-off testing with this and some of
you were actually skeptical about it
when I tweeted about it saying it was
the noise app in the background or some
other things was software that I should
check out but I don't need any more
proof than the fact that when I turned
it off I was getting to noon with 90
plus percent battery life left which is
incredible and that's that's
legitimately 2-day battery life that I
wasn't getting when I turned always-on
back on so that's something I've noticed
at this point I kind of just turned it
on when I want to and then turn it off
when I know I'm gonna be having a longer
day it's only a quick couple taps away
in the settings i switched wrists
sometimes so i'm used to diving in the
settings to change the wrist orientation
so I just do that often I'll just turn
always-on off sometimes so if I'm out at
night I'll usually turn it off because
it's slightly annoying to be the guy
with the glowing wrist all night but in
a normal day at work during the day I'll
leave it on it's a balancing act it's a
little more thinking than I had to do
before but it's also a feature I've
never had before so I guess I'm willing
to do that some other small thoughts the
compass built-in now is pretty sweet I
will literally never use the compass app
but it is cool that it's more accurate
to tell you what direction you're facing
when you're using maps and the noise app
is also kind of cool you can add a
complication to your watch face or just
use the app to monitor noise levels and
it'll tell you when the environment
you're in has potentially damaging
levels of noise and just a thought about
the blob app chooser interface I just
got to say I think this might be the
worst UI in any Apple product in any
tech product in like the last decade I
think we can all agree on that I've
changed it to list mode maybe uh maybe
figure out a grid mode or something for
picking apps on the watch Apple just
saying but overall honestly it's it's
kind of similar to that iPhone 11 review
where like it's an Apple watch like you
already know what it does it's the same
design some subtle tweaks and really one
main new feature I think the fact that
I've disabled the O is on display so
often is kind of hilarious like if you
would disable it if you wouldn't use the
always-on stuff very often then this is
about as good as this series 3 or series
4 in which case you can pick one of
those up from Apple or on Amazon for a
pretty steep discount so I'll link those
below that's a better deal but other
than that I just kind of like the way
the Apple watch has been it's not a
necessary upgrade but for the stuff I
usually do which is having the great
display telling a time workouts
notifications that's just basically it I
mean anything extra as a bonus Apple
watch continues to firmly deliver on all
the things you expect it to and if
you've always wanted always-on then this
is the Apple watch to get but anyway
that's about it quick review but if you
want the next stuff it's coming up quick
its tech Tober there's a lot happening
I've got you guys the next one peace